in this video i will prove to you that
the limit
as x approaches zero
of sine of x
over x
is equal to one but before i do that
before i break into the into
trigonometry i'm going to go over
another i guess aspect of limits and
that's the squeeze theorem because once
you understand what the squeeze theorem
is we can use the squeeze theorem to
prove this there's actually a pretty
involved
explanation but i think you'll find it
pretty neat and satisfying if you get it
if you don't get it maybe you just want
to memorize this because that's a very
useful limit to know later on when we
take the derivatives of trig functions
so what's the squeeze theorem and the
squeeze theorem is my favorite
my favorite theorem
in mathematics possibly because it has
the word squeeze in it
squeeze theorem
and when you read it in a calculus book
it looks all complicated or i don't know
when you read it in a calculus book or a
precalculus book it looks all
complicated but what it's saying is
frankly
pretty obvious let me give you example
if i told you that um
i always so sal
always
eats
more
than
umama
omama is my wife
if i told you that this is true sal
always eats more than a mamma
and then i would also say that sal
always
eats
less
then
then i don't know let me make up a
fictional character then bill
right on at any p on any given day let's
say this in a given day sal always eats
less oh sorry sal always eats more than
obama in any given day and sal always
eats less than bill on any given day now
if i were to tell you that if on
on tuesday
mama
ate 300 calories
and on tuesday bill ate 300 calories
so my question is to you is how many
calories did sal eat or did i eat on
tuesday well i always eat more than a
mama and i always eat well more more or
equal to a mamma and i always eat less
than or equal to bill so then on tuesday
i must have eaten
300 calories so this is the gist of the
squeeze theorem and now i'll do a little
bit more formally but it's essentially
saying if i'm always
greater than than one thing and i'm
always less than another thing and at
some point those two things are equal
well then i must be equal to whatever
those two things are equal i've kind of
been squeezed in between them right i'm
always in between omam and bill and if
they're the exact same point on tuesday
that i must be at that point well or at
least i must approach it so let me write
it in in math terms
so all it says is that if i if you know
over some domain
if i say that
let's say that g of x
is less than or equal to f of x
which is less than or equal to h of x
over some domain
and we also know that the limit
of g of x
as x approaches a is equal to some limit
capital l
and we also know that the limit
as x approaches
a
of h of x
also equals l then the squeeze theorem
tells us and i'm not going to prove that
right here but it's good to just
understand what the squeeze theorem is
the squeeze theorem tells us then the
limit
as x approaches a
of f of x
must also be equal to l and this is the
same thing so i'm you know this is the
example where f of x this could be how
much sal eats in a day this could be how
much umami eats in a day this is bill so
i always eat more than a mamma or less
than bill
and then on tuesday you could say x is
you know a is tuesday
if umami had 300 calories and bill had
300 calories and i also had to eat 300
calories let me let me graph that for
you
let me graph that i'll do a different
color
squeeze theorem
squeeze
squeeze theorem okay so let's let's draw
so let's draw the point a comma l
so let me draw the point a comma l so
let's say this is a that's the point
that we care about a
and this l
and we know let's see g of x that's the
lower function right
so we let's say that this green thing
right here this is g of x
so this is my g of x and we know that as
g of x approaches
so g of x could look something like that
right and we know that the limit as x
approaches a of g of x
is equal to l so that's right there
right so this was g of x
that's g of x
and let me do h of x in a different
color
so now h of x could look something like
this
like that
so that's h of x
and we also know that the limit as x
approaches a
of h of x let's see this is the
this is the this is well this is a
function of x axis
so you could call it h of x
g of x
or
f of x that's just the dependent axis
and this is the x axis
so
once again the limit as x approaches a
of x of h of x well at that point right
there h of a is equal to l or at least
the limit is equal to that we're
assuming
well actually and and none of these
functions actually have to even to be
defined at a as long as these limits
this limit exists and this limit exists
and that that's that's also an important
thing to keep in mind so what what does
this tell us f of x is always greater
than this green function it's always
less than h of x right
so any f of x i draw it would have to be
in between them two right so no matter
how i draw it if i were to draw a
function i could make it go but it's
bounded by those two functions right
just by definition
so it has to go through that point or at
least it has to approach that point
maybe it's not defined at that point
but the limit as we approach a of x of f
of x also has to be at point l and maybe
you know f of x doesn't have to be
defined right there but the limit as we
approach it is going to be l and
hopefully that makes a little bit of
sense and hopefully my calories example
made a little bit of sense to you so
let's keep that in the back of our mind
the squeeze theorem
and now we will use that to prove that
the that the limit
that
the limit
as x approaches 0 of sine of x
over x is equal to 1. and i want to do
that one because this is a super useful
limit and then the other thing is you
know sometimes when you learn the
squeeze theorem you're like oh well
that's obvious but when is it useful and
and we'll see actually i'm going to do
the next video since we're already
pushing eight minutes but we'll see in
the next video that the squeeze theorem
is tremendously useful when we're trying
to prove this i will see you in the next
video